so we had a very good day today the
Republican Party
our country there was no defense of what
Robert Muller was trying to defend in
all fairness sir robert muller whether
his performance was a bad one or a good
one i think everybody understands that i
think everybody understands what's going
on there was no defense to this
ridiculous hoax this witch hunt that's
been going on for a long time pretty
much from the time i came down on the
escalator with our first lady and it's a
disgrace what happened but I think today
proved a lot to everybody in fact some
of my biggest opponents wrote things
today that I wouldn't have believed they
would have written and I appreciate that
they did that this has been a very bad
thing for our country and despite
everything we've been through it's been
an incredible two and a half years for
our country the administration our
president me we've done a great job
we've got the strongest stock market the
best unemployment numbers the most
number of people ever working in the
history of our country right now almost
160 million our military has been
rebuilt and getting even stronger we've
done a great job and we've done it under
this terrible phony cloud a phony cloud
that's all it was and they should be
ashamed of themselves absolutely ashamed
and you know who knew it was a phony
cloud more than anyone else's shift and
Nadler and Schumer and Pelosi every one
of them they all know his phony stuff
and you look at the polls the polls are
showing it maybe more than anybody else
or anything else and I've had my best
calls and I don't say why but people see
what's gone on in our country with this
whole thing I've been going through it
for three years for three years all
nonsense
so this was a very big day for our
country this was a very big day for the
Republican Party and you can say it was
a great day for me but I don't even like
to say that it's great I'll tell you
what
I very much appreciate those incredible
warriors that you watched today on
television Republicans that defended
something and defended something very
powerful very important because they
were really defending our country more
than anything else they would defending
our country but they were warriors and
they've been warriors for a long time
and everybody knew it was a hoax
especially the Democrats I wish we could
be a fly in the wall in those rooms
where the Democrats would go in and talk
before and after meetings and they'd be
laughing and smiling and say can you
believe that we're getting away with
this but in the end they didn't get away
with it yeah
so there is no such a thing he didn't
have the right to exonerate and you know
it's very interesting people mentioned
exoneration that was something where he
totally folded because he never had the
right to exonerate and it was covered
very well by congressman Turner and went
to a conclusion we were if you take a
look at not only the report beyond the
report take a look at not what he said
but what he was forced to say and even
your networks and your network and your
network and you and every one of these
networks they put up their hands you
know we had a couple of cases with
actually we had about six cases where
they asked our people our
representatives television networks
please don't come in tonight we're not
going to be doing much on it and the
reason they're not because it's over
[Music]
so WikiLeaks is a hoax just like
everything else and all of those
problems having to do with crime were
the biggest hoax of all it was a witch
hunt a total witch hunt and when you saw
Robert Muller's statement the earlier
statement and then he did a recap he did
a correction later on in the afternoon
and you know what that correction was
and you still ask the question you know
why because you're fake dudes and you're
one of the most and let me just tell you
the fact that you even asked that
question you're fake news because you
know what he totally corrected himself
in the afternoon and you know that just
as well as anybody Caitlyn Caitlyn I
don't know whose answers weren't I guess
his answers weren't because if you look
the whole report you take a look at what
they did some of the things that he
didn't even know about some of the
things he didn't even know what was
going on but you know in the end what he
did he actually probably came through
for himself the performance was
obviously not very good he had a lot of
problems but what he showed more than
anything else is that this whole thing
has been three years of embarrassment
and waste of time for our country and
you know what the Democrats thought they
could win an election like this I think
they hurt themselves very badly for 2020
did I watch I don't know I really don't
know I never had don't know yeah good
frankly whether or not he did wouldn't
matter to me because he did nothing
wrong he did nothing wrong
it's important it was always a very
unimportant meeting it was only
important to the fake news go ahead no
we didn't say that again your fake news
and you're right at the top of the list
also let me just tell you go back to
what it's not what he said read his
correction read his correction if you
read his correction you'll find out
that's why people don't deal with you
because you're not an honest reporter
shot
[Music]
John
they are devastated the Democrats lost
so big today their party is in shambles
right now they've got the squad leading
their party they are a mess we're even
you take a look at scribe and you take a
look at so many of the people that were
the most outspoken and they say this was
a devastating day for the Democrats and
you know it John and everybody else
knows it this was a devastating day for
the Democrat very dumb and very unfair
question because if you look at his
correction he took that totally out of
play he made his decision based on the
facts not based on some rule so you
shouldn't even ask that question because
you know it's a phony
the Democrats had nothing and now they
have less than nothing and I think
they're going to lose the 20/20 election
very big including congressional seats
because of the path that they chose now
who knows where it goes from what I hear
they're giving up but I just say I know
them too well they'll never give up
they'll go back into the room and
they'll try and figure something out
this whole thing has been honestly it's
been collusion it's been collusion with
the media it's been collusion with other
countries this has been a disaster for
the Democrat and I think we're going to
win bigger than ever now I'm I'm going
to West Virginia one of the great states
a state that's doing if you look at
percentage up I think it's number one or
number two in the country and nobody
would have believed that West Virginia
is doing great so I'm going to West
Virginia we did have a big case today
you know we won the asylum case in
Washington which frankly you should be
asking about that because that's the
real deal I can't believe how nice you
are today go ahead give me a question
no because we did nothing wrong the
answer is very simple nothing was done
wrong this was all the big hoax and if
you look at it today nothing was done
wrong now I believe what you're gonna
find
you're gonna find a lot of things that
were done very wrong but that's going on
now that's something you haven't been
writing about and that has to do with
the other side that has to do with the
thing called investigate the
investigators let's see what happens
that's going to be very much
[Music]
look I think Robert Muller did a
horrible job both today and with respect
to the investigation but in all fairness
to Robert Muller he had nothing to work
with you know you can be a builder but
if they don't give you the right
materials you're not going to build a
very good building Robert Muller had no
material he had nothing to work with so
obviously he did very poorly today I
don't think there's anybody even among
the fakers I don't think there's anybody
that would say he did well I looked at
your people they're saying it was
devastating for the Democrats and even I
will tell you the two most nauseous and
nauseating networks whose ratings have
both gone down way down even they said
this was a really bad day for the
Democrats
so Robert Muller did a poor job but in
all fairness to him he had nothing to
work with David
look I know what he did to people how he
ruined people's lives because they
didn't remember a date for something
very minor he ruined people's lives the
Democrats they took people and they
destroyed their lives they went bankrupt
because they couldn't afford the legal
fees and they were good people many many
people so when you ask me that question
all they have to do is see that how nice
this weather is if I made a mistake and
said I was talking to the media and it
was a little bit rainy a little bit
overcast and say well we have to do he
lied let me tell you I've seen what
they've done to people I've seen how
they've destroyed people like general
Flynn and so many others what they've
done to people no I did the right thing
[Music]
well Baba had no material sure Butler
had no material to work with and he did
a horrible job but obviously his recent
a she was way off but that's okay
it didn't matter we had no material
there was nothing done wrong in fact
things were done right there was nothing
done wrong and certainly I mean look I
read the papers that I read the press
and I read the Internet and if you see
what's going on the internet if you
listen to the Internet this was one of
the worst performances in the history of
our country so you know that you know
that very well but I don't think anybody
could have done a good performance
we had no material it was a fake set of
facts that the Democrats used to add
others the dry as new really
overthrow but we're gonna find out
[Music]
well the asylum is a big dance so the
asylum is a very big ruling that was a
tremendous ruling today we appreciate it
we respect the courts very much that
helps us very much at the border the
numbers are way down at the border which
is a good thing apprehensions are way
down because Mexico has now 22,000
soldiers and there they mean business
because they know what happens we
alternative is not good for them it's
also good for Mexico what they're doing
because the cartels have been running
all of the border for years and years
and Mexico is saying and the president
is saying we got to clean it up so
they've got 21 thousand soldiers they'll
probably put up four but this ruling
today and asylum is a tremendously
[Music]
so Guatemala gave us their word we were
going to sign a safe third agreement and
then all of a sudden they backed up they
said it was their Supreme Court I don't
believe that but they use their supreme
court as the reason that he want to do
it so we'll leave the new tariffs or
we'll do something we're looking at
something very severe with respect to
Guatemala I've already cut all payments
I did that a year ago I cut all cut
payments going to Honduras El Salvador
and Guatemala we used to send them five
hundred million dollars for nothing but
nothing they didn't do anything except
set up caravans so Guatemala we're going
to take care of and it won't even be
tough we're going to do we're looking at
a couple of different things one of the
things very heavy is as you know Mexico
has put six thousand people on that
border
let me just tell you something I know
you're always I always have a question
you mean my White House aides life what
about his age what about what about
mother's age he didn't say that at all
you're untruthful when you ask you are
untrue when you ask that question when
you ask that question you're under foe
and you know who else is untruthful you
know who else is untruthful his aides
and Weitzman was untruthful and Weissman
got caught just like he did with Arthur
Andersen where he lost in the Supreme
Court nine to nothing
his aides were very intrusive and they
put Muller and they put Mullen not at
all they put Muller in a very bad
position
his aides put him in a very bad position
and if you were ever truthful he'd be
able to write
[Music]
I'm very happy that he was buried
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
and then by
[Music]
and what color did
[Music]
and I got
[Music]
[Music]